salud en directo América de France 24 y
ya está conmigo en el estudio Marina
sardina Marina bienvenida buena mañana
el lunes vamos a hablar de esta nueva
batalla legal por la patente de la
vacuna de ARN mensajero desarrollada por
moderna y Es que el viernes a
farmacéutica denunció a pfizer Byron por
qué Por copiar digamos sin permiso
partes de sus innovadora tecnología de
ARN mensajero Marina y haberle ajustado
para desarrollar sus propias vacunas
contra el covid 19 como se ha ido
desarrollando esto y queda de nuevo
Buenos días si la guerra contra de las
patentes siguen curso y la verdad es que
no nos sorprende la farmacéutica moderna
Presenta una demanda por infracción de
patentes en Estados Unidos y Alemania
por propiedad intelectual de la vacuna
con tecnología como decías ARN mensajero
ya que considera que pfizer y bayon Tech
copiaron dos partes claves de su
innovadora tecnología la primera una
modificación química particular sobre el
ADN que ayuda a despertar una respuesta
inmune adecuada y la segunda la
codificación de una parte de los
coronavirus que usan para infectar las
células y que es necesario para
codificar y saber contra qué se debe
proteger el cuerpo veamos lo que dijo la
empresa en un comunicado
presentamos estas demandas para proteger
la innovadora plataforma de tecnología
ARN mensajero en la que fuimos Pioneros
en la que invertimos miles de millones
de dólares para su creación y que
patentamos durante la década anterior a
la pandemia de Kobe 19
moderno asegura que ha infringido las
patentes presentadas entre 2010 y 2016
Cuando comenzó a desarrollar esta
novedosa tecnología con los primeros
ensayos clínicos en humanos probados en
2015 por su parteca asegura que sus
invenciones son originales y fruto de la
investigación moderna prometió hace
tiempo No implementar sus patentes de la
vacuna contra el Kobe 19 en los países
de ingresos bajos y medios pero desde
marzo de este año reclama que su
propiedad intelectual se respete en los
países ricos Raúl Marina seguimos
andando en ese tema recordemos entonces
que es la tecnología de ARN mensajero Y
cómo actúa la tecnología de ARN
mensajero es una molécula esencial para
la vida se encarga de transmitir el
mensaje de la vida contenido en el ADN y
convertirlo en todas las proteínas para
desempeñar todas las funciones vitales
digamos que es un material genético que
le dice al cuerpo como producir
proteínas por lo general las vacunas
introducen en el cuerpo una partícula
inofensiva de una bacteria o de un virus
particular causando una respuesta
inmunitaria sin embargo este tipo de
vacuna la molécula ARN mensajero en vez
de una parte de la bacteria o virus
introduce este tipo de molécula el ARN
mensajero se enseña le enseña las
células como producir copias de la
proteína s las vacunas con esta
tecnología funcionan al introducir un
fragmento de ARN mensajero que
corresponde a la proteína vital y como
parte de la respuesta inmunitaria normal
el sistema inmunitario reconoce la
proteína que es extraña y produce
anticuerpos que ayudan a proteger
nuestro organismo de infecciones
permaneciendo en nuestro cuerpo incluso
después de eliminar el patógeno Para
futuras exposiciones
tecnología está empezando a usarse
clínicamente también Raúl para
desarrollar otras vacunas contratas
enfermedades Como por ejemplo el VIH
exactamente que también la está probando
precisamente moderna Marina Gracias por
toda esta introducción quede con
nosotros por favor para profundizar
sobre ese tema con nuestro segundo
invitado al día
[Música]
y seguimos hablando de este tema de
salud lo que está pasando con el
laboratorio moderno infarse y pfizer
bayon Tech como bien lo decía Marina
sardina que me acompaña entonces en esta
mesa de trabajo está demanda que le pone
moderna a pfizer Byron Tech por
supuestamente copiar esta tecnología de
patentes de ARN mensajero en su vacuna
de Kobe 19 para futuros desarrollos de
más vacunas marinas
nosotros tenemos al nuestro invitado él
es Daniel
sí que nos acompaña y ese epidemiólogo y
es director de acción sanitaria de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud Buenos
días Daniel y gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en France 24 lo primero
cuéntanos de qué se trata esta guerra
por una por la propiedad intelectual y
cómo va a afectar esto al desarrollo de
las futuras vacunas
Bueno lo primero es apuntar claramente
que estamos en presencia de una guerra
comercial de una guerra de intereses
económicos de una guerra por codicia y
no de una disputa sanitaria
Lamentablemente ocurre en un momento muy
poco oportuno y yo creo que es una
expresión del camino que no tenía que
tomarse ni debe tomarse en el futuro
para el desarrollo de vacunas en contra
de pandemias que están asolando a la
humanidad entera las patentes se pueden
convertir en un obstáculo para el acceso
efectivo de la vacuna a la población en
todo el mundo pero sobre todo esta
disputa lo único que hace es confrontar
a las dos empresas que tienen que
producir la vacuna ahora la vacuna
bivalente que también de respuesta a las
nuevas variantes o micro Y esto puede
afectar seriamente la capacidad de
producción
y la la posibilidad de hacer efectiva
las dosis de vacunas que vamos a
necesitar para hacer un nuevo ciclo de
vacunación para toda la población
Entonces yo Considero que es poco
afortunada y poco oportuna esta disputa
que esencialmente obedece a la codicia a
querer tener parte de la ganancia de lo
que fue facturado por pfizer moderna ha
tenido una ganancia naturalmente enorme
y no estamos en presencia de un proceso
de cooperación estamos en presencia de
un proceso de demandas legales para
generar un beneficio económico no un
beneficio sanitario Daniel Buendía un
gusto saludarlo entonces teniendo este
panorama como ustedes Viendo acá de
explicar está en peligro la
comercialización de la vacuna contra el
covid 19 con esta tecnología de ARN
mensajero
bueno está en peligro la estabilidad
para la producción por parte de ambas
empresas y con ello la comercialización
y con ello el acceso efectivo de la
población a la vacuna que va a ser
necesaria y que ha sido necesaria Yo
creo que el comités externo de
evaluación de la gestión de la pandemia
que fue convocado por la OMS desde mayo
del 2021 señaló que había un gran
problema de inequidad en la distribución
de las vacunas en el acceso a las
vacunas y en las coberturas vacunales y
que uno de los obstáculos fundamentales
era el que no se habían flexibilizado
las patentes para que hubiese un proceso
de cooperación mundial con la producción
de vacunas como bienes públicos globales
No únicamente como objetos de Mercado
que generan una ganancia yo creo que
como sociedad como como orden
internacional tenemos que de
posicionarnos Y definir vamos a
construir una sanitaria mundial con
bienes públicos globales o vamos a ser
Víctimas de las disputas y de las
especulaciones de Mercado que puedan
tener las empresas farmacéuticas parte
de lo cual es la disputa por las
patentes Daniel y cuéntanos un poco con
esta demanda deben facer y retirar sus
vacunas de ARN Mensajero del Mercado o
no deben hacerlo no en estos momentos lo
que se ha hecho es poner una demanda en
un en un tribunal tanto en Estados
Unidos como en Alemania estos tribunales
tendrán que analizar que tendrán que
llegar a un a un dictamen decía en
efecto hay una violación a las reglas de
patente o de propiedad intelectual y lo
que está buscando moderno es una
indemnización no que se retiren las
vacunas del mercado eso yo creo que ya
sería criminal porque sería tanto como
cortar en buena medida los suministros
esenciales para seguir combatiendo
contra la pandemia mover buscando es una
compensación multimillonaria si es que
en efecto se violó esta disposición de
propiedad intelectual pero yo insisto yo
creo que tenemos que poner en entredicho
la pertinencia de estas regulaciones de
propiedad intelectual cuando estamos
tratando de trabajar por un bien público
que alcance a todos los ciudadanos del
mundo eso le quería preguntar
precisamente a Daniel que se lleven las
vacunas considerarse bienes comunes
mundiales no porque estamos hablando de
la salud de toda una población en este
caso con la pandemia lo vemos la salud y
y Pues digamos la supervivencia
de nuestra especie de los humanos Así es
Yo soy partidario de que consideremos
las vacunas y más aún las vacunas que
usamos para luchar contra una pandemia
como bienes públicos globales la
seguridad sanitaria mundial el que no
tengamos riesgos amenazantes para la
salud como una pandemia depende de la
cooperación internacional del bien
público global no de bienes objetivos no
de competencias económicas no de reglas
de patentes que frenen el acceso de la
población a los bienes esenciales para
poder cuidar de su salud yo creo que en
esto tenemos que que pensar mucho más en
que se tiene que construir este marco de
actuación hoy que se hoy por hoy que se
está discutiendo un nuevo tratado
pandémico en el seno de la OMS yo creo
que las cosas tienen que ir hasta el
punto de discutir esta cooperación
internacional y este orden diferente que
tiene que existir para la producción de
vacunas cuando enfrentamos una pandemia
también cuéntanos un poco Daniel Cómo
afecta esta batalla legal a la
desigualdad que ya existe como
comentabas en este acceso a la vacuna
especialmente en los países del sur
global donde vimos que las donaciones y
todas estas campañas que se hicieron al
principio pues no fueron realmente
efectivas y no han llegado las dosis
suficientes a esa población
para responder a tu pregunta de alguna
manera me gustaría decir ya me gustaría
a mí que moderna dijese que si obtiene
una compensación económica por esta
disputa legal la va a aplicar a el
mecanismo kovacs o a la distribución de
vacunas en países pobres pero no es eso
lo que está ocurriendo está hablando de
conseguir un beneficio económico para
sus accionistas para sus arcas no no
para la cooperación internacional en
estos momentos cualquier disputa legal
va a entorpecer la producción y va a
encarecer incluso la producción y Esto
va a ser una barrera de acceso
especialmente para los países pobres y
para mí esto es una contribución a la
inequidad no una contribución a la
resolución del problema de inequidad en
la distribución de vacunas
claro Daniel digamos que entonces Cómo
podemos Buscar otras alternativas
digamos de alguna manera inmediatas para
esta suspensión de patentes
bueno las alternativas existen Existen
los instrumentos legales en el marco de
la Organización Mundial del Comercio y
de la Organización Mundial de la Salud
pero particularmente es potestad de la
Organización Mundial de comercio
establecer una liberación de patentes
Esto fue pedido por los países pobres
desde el inicio de la pandemia pero no
fue aceptado Esto fue recomendado por el
comité experto asesor independiente de
la OMS pero no se llevó a cabo esto ya
se ha producido en algún momento cuando
se inició la producción de medicamentos
antirretrovirales para la lucha contra
el sida cuando eran de un precio tan
inaccesible que no permitía tener una
cobertura adecuada de los enfermos y se
negoció una una cláusula llamada
composery License Así que en esencial
liberaba las patentes para la producción
de estos medicamentos para ponerlo en
pocas palabras si se quiere se puede
hacer hay el marco para poderlo hacer
pero países tienen que llegar ese
acuerdo en el marco de la Organización
Mundial del Comercio Daniel y sabemos
que hay otras enfermedades que están
empezando a investigarse a través y a
producir vacunas o su investigación está
en curso para a través de esta mecanismo
de tecnología ARN mensajero Cómo puede
afectar este tipo de demandas al
desarrollo de estas nuevas vacunas
contra otro tipo de enfermedades y a su
investigación
en la tecnología de ha sido ribonucleico
Mensajero de r de ARN mensajero pues nos
ha dado un gran salto cualitativo en el
desarrollo de las vacunas contra la pero
podría darnos para resolver otros
problemas de salud otras vacunas otros
tratamientos en donde se puede inducir a
través de esta tecnología la producción
de proteínas en las células humanas que
permitan pues generar una inmunidad
contra los daños que están produciendo
otras enfermedades yo creo que lo que
debemos de pensar es que este tipo de
hallazgos o tecnologías no pueden ser
únicamente una patente para generar
un un ingreso o una ganancia a una
compañía tiene que ser parte del
conocimiento mundial para propósitos del
avance de la ciencia mundial y ahí es en
donde creo que la codicia puede frenar
el avance científico
Daniel es gracias por su tiempo por
estar con nosotros en directo América de
Francia de 4 esta mañana de lunes se nos
acaba el tiempo para seguir hablando
sobre ese tema tan importante que tiene
bastantes aristas y ahí entra Pues dónde
está los límites no lo moral el bien
común Lo privado Pues el desarrollo y
todo esto Daniel que pues intentamos de
analizarlo y hablar un poco con usted
esta mañana de lunes como siempre
Gracias por estar con nosotros un abrazo
un placer un abrazo gracias Marina
también por toda la información Daniel
López Acuña pidemiólogo y ex director de
acción o sanitaria de la Organización
Mundial de la Salud nosotros continuamos
esto es directo América
[Música]